I'm Jordan and today I'm assisting at a photo shoot.
I keep track of it all using my Lumia...
...as it allows me to do many different things, all at once.
I'm an aspiring photographer myself...
...and I take pictures whenever I get a chance.
I like the rawness of "behind the scenes" material.
It's just too good not to share.
A lot more goes into a photo shoot than people might think.
You often end up making last-minute changes on the go.
Cortana is my intelligent personal assistant.
He helps me keep my life on track.
Skype comes in handy when I need to call clients in other countries...
...and, I have a few minutes, I might sneak in a quick gaming session...
...but I'm always ready to jump straight back into work.